la periodista cynthia valdez sufrió
amenazas de muerte de un grupo criminal
en su estado natal sinaloa el mecanismo
del gobierno de protección para
periodistas la traslado a ciudad de
méxico y le dio refugio tres años
después ella decidió volver a su lugar
de origen a ejercer nuevamente su labor
a pesar de sentir que las autoridades la
abandonaron en este proceso se
estableció un plan de retorno en
conjunto con la ciudad pero sin embargo
hasta la fecha no se ha acordado ninguna
medida me dejaron en la total
indefensión al perder yo mis medidas de
seguridad porque ni siquiera tengo un
monitoreo ya de policía federal ni de
ninguna institución de seguridad en
sinaloa aula saucedo de artículo 19
advierte que las medidas del gobierno
para proteger a periodistas en peligro
se limitan a un enfoque reactivo que no
hay prevención en las medidas que se dan
yo te doy una medida de protección pero
que al yo no investigar estas amenazas
de dónde vienen no generarte condiciones
para para aumentar los costos de que te
agregan te van a seguir agrediendo un
mar bello es otro periodista en riesgo
que debió abandonar su natal guerrero
tras ser víctima de secuestro y amenazas
lleva cuatro años en un refugio en
ciudad de méxico y su única medida de
protección es un botón de pánico
esto me da más para que sepan dónde
queda estés
realmente de que aquello le apachurro
aquí el botón y se dan cuenta ya me
mataron
al sufrir la agresión tenía ocho años
trabajando de manera formal en un
periódico de zihuatanejo hoy no logra
conseguir empleo y una de las
consecuencias de ser desplazado y de
estar bajo el mecanismo es que pierdes
entre otras cosas tu vida laboral
cintia y omar tuvieron la fortuna de ser
protegidos a tiempo la misma suerte no
la tuvieron los cinco periodistas
asesinados entre el 15 de enero y el 10
de febrero de 2022 con lo que ya suman
29 en el sexenio actual el 90 por ciento
de los crímenes contra periodistas en el
país quedan impunes